[Music]
this is what happens when Stardust meets
a passionate fan base who have waited 15
years to return to the football league
[Applause]
wrexham's promotion parade gave the
community a chance to celebrate their
Heroes
picking the streets with streaks of red
and white
I mean I've been watching them years in
non-league you got all these good
players and bigger teams to take them
we've got a bigger budget now we can
keep the good players we've got to work
our way up slowly enjoy the process that
was unbelievable it's one of the best
experiences of my life wrexham all the
way through come on what these two guys
have done to this the team and the town
absolutely brilliant
2021 takeover by stars Ryan Reynolds and
Rob mcelhenney this team has found
investment and an international fan base
a story straight from a motion picture
the Hollywood owners were here today to
drink it all in
wrexham's Newfound success isn't just
about the team but the community around
the Club
International attention to a local team
in this corner of North Wales
attention that has seen benefits for
local businesses wrexham doesn't stand
alone you know for towns that are you
know you know of economically struggled
in the last
decade or so you know austerities kicked
in in wrexham and parts and you know
it's it's been a bit of a struggle you
know but you know what this does do is
it brings people into the town it gets
people spending it gets businesses
earning a little bit more which creates
jobs and everybody knows enough on
effect from that
[Music]
[Applause]
they don't want to stop here the dream
is to one day compete in the Premier
League
that might seem far away but fans here
and around the world are hoping their
team's Hollywood Revival has only just
begun shinki marike Sky News Rexel
[Music]